we have a david pakman show subreddit at
david pakman.com slash our EDD i.t
closing in on 6,000 of our viewers and
listeners participating in political
discussions there I encourage you to
join and a few interesting discussions
that caught my eye this morning when I
was on the subreddit imagine what the
stock market will do the day the Moller
the day muller presents to Congress or
in Deitz Trump yeah I don't know that
those things are going to happen right
because of the stock market instability
over the last week or so I have been
thinking what would happen to the stock
market if indeed the President of the
United States were to be indicted or
forced into resignation or impeached in
a serious manner it would probably be
pretty bad for those retirement accounts
to say it would go down we don't know
how severely though yeah and we don't
know if it would be permanent right they
could be sort of temporary jitters that
would eventually recover but it would
get crazy and it's been crazy right
we've had put you know plus 500 down
1,100 up 300 down 300 it's been wacky
and and if the Moller investigation
really gets going which I don't even
believe it has yet it's going to get
even crazier also from the subreddit
what about rebranding taxes as public
investments this is an interesting post
from one of our subscribers on the
subreddit about trying to take control
of the language around taxes to make it
more left friendly and sort of more
patriotic to be investing through taxes
in your country this is not a new idea
george lakoff one of the masters of
analyzing political framing and language
he has been speaking for a while about
the failure of the left to frame taxes
as a patriotic investment in the future
of your country now has it failed
because it's not a winning idea as it
failed because it just hasn't really
been tried hard enough by the left I
don't know but it is an interesting idea
and George Lakoff is actually written
about it I like public investments more
than I do
Republicans are soft on tax yes I do I
guess there's a little bit more
effective we covered that other one last
year someone said last week or the
weekend where someone said what about
branding Republicans are soft on taxes
when they want low taxes for the
super-rich I think branding taxes is a
patriotic public investment is better
also from our subreddit what do you
think pac-man's top secret hatred mail
vetting technique is there's no specific
top secret hatred mail vetting technique
we've mentioned before that we have a
way of trying to deduce whether people
are writing fake hate mail to try to get
on to hatred mail or whether they are
genuine yeah it's not that it's like
some secret algorithm it's I just don't
want to mention exactly what we do
because that would make it easier for
fake hatred mail to get by it but but
it's not some amazingly complex
algorithm it's just we have certain ways
that we do it I would call it extreme
vetting right maybe so maybe so and but
and you know the key thing is if you're
doing extreme betting you don't want to
tell the bad guys what the methods on
our because you don't want to expect
expose sources and methods so we're
leaving it a secret we're leaving it a
secret but it's not that crazy of what
we have going on and lastly from the
subreddit David makes the trademark all
right okay sign as he announces his
show's merger within four words yeah
this is funny when we did the story
about putting a bumper sticker over an
Infowars bumper sticker I in a certain
point you can cut away from this sure I
put up I just did a thumbs up and I okay
sign or or I'm sorry not a thumbs up and
okay sign yeah and I guess in some
circles that's considered an alright
thing or I guess it also makes a w like
for whites I mean that's supposed to be
a white supremacy calling card I can't
believe that I was sitting here right
across from you and I missed it it's
just like how and you the birthday
celebration you've made a reference to
George Soros right by saying that you're
going to drown your sorrows I didn't
notice that yes it was very subtle I
know you tried to get away with it but
you got caught let's cut all of this out
from the show because this this
certainly backfired but in any case I'm
not a white supremacist and we can all
sort of be pleased with that I guess
join us on the subreddit david
pakman.com slash our EDD i tea